anything I can help you out with Kevin I
I can answer any question you like yeah
so I was wondering if somebody was
visiting the US for the first time
what's the one bit of American History
they should know oh that's good that's a
really
um that's a really good question I think
if you're visiting the United States are
you going to drive around is that if
you're going to drive around that's
important I think so yeah because I mean
I one of the most iconic things to do I
guess in the US because of how the
highways are are there I think it's
driving you know yeah it's one of those
California to New York trips I I think
it would be like fantastic yes yeah
Route 66 I think that's an amazing thing
to do I I also have to say the American
Civil War I mean we had a civil war here
um 1861 to 65 that was in at the time
the largest largest battles ever in
world history and uh it was the clash of
the north versus the South and so when
you drive even if you started in
California and drove across but if you
worked your way through the American
South and then up towards the north
you'd see all kinds of amazing
battlefields and you'd kind of
understand how this country has always
had issues I mean like a lot of
countries but it's had it's had a lot of
uh conflict it's at a lot of people with
different opinions about how to run the
country yeah our cartels are in the
Senate in the house okay
Jesus
I'm sorry today's episode brought to you
by Bill Maher but it's I think that's
that's worth that's worth uh looking
into I mean because there's a lot of
things to see and also I think it
informs you a little bit about today's
America we're we're still not quite
getting along and seen to eye to eye and
some people think we're gonna fight with
each other again although I think we're
way too interested in streaming content
I think
everyone's just going to be watching
Netflix and Hulu and forget you know
just let the streaming Wars like the the
Liberals will adhere to you know HBO Max
and apple plus and the conservatives
take Hulu and peacock and then you know
yeah I'm fine with that division my
contribution level to this episode well
it's um for amount of time speaking
quite High okay for actual contribution
to the flow uh that's a different number
okay I just want to know how you're
being served I'm I'm running this no no
I'm gonna fill out the survey after
we're done I get a survey that's only
for Matt not for anyone else after we're
done I understand but I don't know do
you think that's a because I know you're
a history buff too is that a valid thing
to mention especially if you go up to
the the Northeast there you could do
those and then you could end at the
Smithsonian and then get a huge dose of
All American history pop culture science
all that and there there might be a riot
while you're there you know so sure
music history is also pretty fantastic
Memphis go see Memphis New Orleans with
the Jazz scene or of course uh Tennessee
with everything that it has Memphis with
Graceland and all that stuff it's pretty
nice yeah I'll get to get your grunge
fixed
oh that's true too does it still that's
way out of the way I don't know you just
great if you looked at a map of the US
and sort of what we were describing your
suggestion is a perfect illustration of
where you've been taking the
conversation today yeah
yeah you're in New Orleans and then
you're in Memphis Seattle
Seattle yeah because of the music in
1991. and then I'd get up to that great
Alaskan music scene that they have
Anchorage things are really hopping in
Anchorage